I think this is exciting. The David Pakman
Show is hiring. We have a small team and we
very rarely have open positions. I get emails all
the time from people wanting to intern or work
part time or offering their services in different
ways. And we essentially are almost never hiring.
We are. Is it lucky, blessed, fortunate that
many of our our employees stay a really long time
and we have a position that is available. And
I want to tell you about it in case you want to
apply or, you know, somebody that might want to
apply. I will tell you at the end of this segment
how to express interest. And if you do anything
outside of what I'm saying to express interest,
we're unfortunately going to have to ignore it
because we have to set some guidelines and create
some structure here. So this is a position that
is remote. You can be anywhere for this position.
But that being said, we mostly
are working on east eastern U.S.
time zone. All right. This is a multidisciplinary
position that includes social media and writing.
It includes video editing. It includes publishing
of content. And, yes, it includes some sales. No,
get it? No, no cold calling people on the phone,
but yes, interacting with a possible advertisers
and brands via email. So I think the easiest way
to explain this position to be would be to tell
you kind of like what a typical day would look
like. The typical day would start with making
a bunch of social media content and scheduling
posts, maybe for that day, maybe for the weekend.
This includes to our Instagram, this includes
Twitter, this includes Facebook, Tic-Tac,
et cetera, and other platforms we're going
to expand to. So first piece of it would be
working with the team to figure out what did well
yesterday on YouTube. Let's amplify some of that
stuff. What funny memes do we have on Reddit,
cetera? All right. That's piece one of the day.
Second part of the day. We are looking very
strongly at launching a second YouTube channel.
We have so much live stream content right now that
there's lots of things that happen on live streams
that would be very flippable as individual clips.
But our main YouTube channel is essentially full
with the clips from the podcast and interviews
and this type of thing. So the ideal person
would be able to understanding the culture of the
show. And what's interesting and what's funny,
go through the previous day's live stream and pick
out a handful of moments, either live calls or
reviews of clips or whatever the case may be.
That would be good standalone clips for this
second YouTube channel working under the tutelage
of producer Pat, cutting these, titling them,
understanding metadata thumbnails, click bait
titles. Obviously, you know what we will teach
you click bait titles and managing this potential
second YouTube channel. Very good. That's part
two. So we've got social media and this new
second channel we are thinking of. Part three
is working under the tutelage of producer and
business development mastermind Noah. To do some
sales outreach and this some people may know this,
some people may not. We do ad sales not just for
The David Pakman Show but also for other shows. We
are almost, in a sense, an ad agency and we want
to expand that. So working under the tutelage of
Noah, you would learn how do we grow our list of
shows on which we place sponsors? How do we make
initial contact with sponsors? And hopefully you
would get to the point of negotiating your own
deals as well. That would be part three of the job
and then part. Well, I guess those those are the
three main parts. And then the other thing would
be also learning the technical production of the
show. How is the show carried out on a daily basis
such that if we were to have an illness like,
for example, when I had my appendectomy? Well,
Pat, Pat filled in for me, but but you wouldn't
be expected to fill in for me. But what if Pat
was out? What if we had, you know, whatever? You
would essentially learn to be a backup producer
for the show as well. So this for the right person
would be full time. It also may start as part time
and that would be absolutely fine. It would
eventually be a full time job with benefits.
The key things are less about technical know how
we've learned that we can really teach people all
of the tech skills. What we can't teach is being
a really good writer and written communicator.
We can't teach, go get them type attitude and
people being a go getters. We can't necessarily
teach, you know, working well in a fast paced
environment and working on four or five different
things each day. So those are really the big
things. We are setting a requirement that you
either have to have a college degree already or
be in your last semester right now. And that is
for a number of different reasons and to
reduce certain certain complications if you
want to apply. We have a formal job description
that I can send. You can inquire with a letter
of interest and resume or without one just asking
for the position description. The only way to send
inquiries about this job is info at David Pakman
dot com. And please make the subject of your email
job opening. OK, in the email, please confirm
that you either have a college degree or are in
your last semester. Tell me a little bit
about meeting those requirements of being a
good written communicator, working well in teams,
working well in a fast paced environment, etc..
And we are going to we anticipate I mentioned
this on the stream yesterday. We're already
getting a lot of interest. So we anticipate a
lot of interest and it's very, very exciting.
The team is growing. We are growing content. We
are growing a lot of different things. All right.
I've said way too much. I've gone on for a long
time. But hopefully that gives you a sense of
what's going on. And info at David Pakman
Dotcom is the one and only place to inquire.
No voicemails, no visits to producer
Pats apartment, none of that. All right.